BASTIEN LEGRAS: So now we're
going to talk about Cloud
Storage, which is
one compartment
of the Cloud Platform.
So why Cloud Storage?
What is Cloud Storage?
So the general challenge we
detected in the market on
Cloud Storage and on storage in
general is that people have
more and more difficulty to
patch the system, to do
replication, to do disaster
recovery, to locate storage.
And that's why we thought that
because at Google, we have a
huge infrastructure, we have a
lot of hard drives and a lot
of capacity of storage, we could
help people store data--
companies, large companies,
as well--
by giving them an easy solution
to store any type of
object up to four terabytes.
And this object is ultimately
replicated in our cloud.
And because we own our
bandwidth, all of the fibers
between our data centers, we
can do live replication.
So the idea is that you can
upload from anywhere, and have
the files available from any
of the data centers.
So you can have a global
storage system for your
application, and for your
backend, if you are in a
mobile application development
scenario.
So the main use case, as we
see, content sharing.
Some people now are using Cloud
Storage directly to
offload the bandwidth of their
website, because you can link
heavy files directly to cloud
storage, because there is an
HTTP URL that is associated
with each of the files.
And if you make the file public,
the idea is that
people can download
directly the file.
And because we have what we call
an edge cache at Google,
so we have thousands of network
infrastructure in the
world, the idea is that the
first one is going to pull the
files from the data center.
That would be copied
in our edge cache.
And the next one will only
go to the edge cache.
So a practical example--
imagine you store in Central
Europe your files.
Someone in Italy goes on your
website or uses your mobile
application, requests the file--
so it can be an update
of the application.
The file will be stored clearly
in one of the main
cities in Italy, so the next one
won't have to go back to
Central Europe or US.
It will be much faster in terms
of latency, and in terms
of bandwidth as well.
Archive backup, so that's
quite obvious.
Data sharing, because the idea
is that you can share an
object to any Google account
directly, in, of course, a
very secure way.
So the idea is that we have
companies in the cinema who
wants to have the
original movie.
They will store it and exchange
it from New York or
Hollywood to Europe directly
using Cloud Storage, because
this is very secure
and very fast.
Storage for applications,
of course,
and for Compute Engine.
Compute Engine, because for all
the HPC in I/O, like High
Performance Computing, people
usually need to crunch a large
amount of binary data.
And they need to have that
central storage, and to
request it to do the computation
on each of the
machines, and then give
back the results.
So that's another use case.
So as I said, the idea is not
like one hard drive on one
server in one data center
with Cloud Storage.
This is really a global
solution.
This is something we
are using at Google
for a lot of projects.
And on the left side, we have
some ideas of which projects
are using it.
So what we really think is key
there is the performance of
the networks, the accessibility
to the file, and
the replication, so the high
availability of the file.
So that's why we have
SLAs 99.95 on
these kinds of solutions.
The network, again-- so between
data centers, between
data centers and the end users,
this is usually our
network up to the very last
mile, which is a telco.
There will be from the user to
our point of presence maybe,
let's say, fast web.
And as soon as they go into
our fast web peering
agreement, because we have
peering agreements with all
the telcos, then you are
on Google network.
And then it goes really,
really fast.
As I said, so it's up to five
terabytes per object.
I will show you it.
So you have--
we call them buckets.
You see it like a folder, and
then within buckets, you can
create these kind of folders,
and upload, modify, archive.
You can do so also versioning.
There's a lot of features.
OK, I don't want to repeat
myself too much, but it's
really about speed, reliability,
and scalability,
in terms of storage.
We have customers right now who
are storing more than 10
petabytes of data.
Next.
How does it work?
How can you use it?
So as always, this is an
API, so a RESTful API.
And we, as always, have three
ways that you can connect.
So you have the API directly,
if you need to do deep
integration with your
application.
We have a common tool
called gsutil, and I
will show it after.
And we have also the UI,
so in the browser.
And I will show it as well.
So you can browse your files
when you are testing.
So the API, so as I said,
RESTful buckets and objects.
So the idea is that that's
really a snippet of what you
can do, just put on HTTP.
So we do, as always, the client
API to help you save
some time, if you want to use
the Java client, or the .NET
client or whatever language to
save some time and not work at
the HTTP level.
And of course, by REST, we
mean HTTP headers, so
really a pure HTTP.
So you can connect--
what it means is that you
can connect from nearly
everywhere, and any kind
of technology.
It is very easy to
be the connector.
And we have an ecosystem of
partners who are providing
appliances to the storage.
Some features, so you can do
streaming, resumable transfer--
so if you have a large file
upload or download, and the
connection point is broken,
then you can resume at the
precise byte where
you were stopped.
Optimized browser upload and
download, and also you can do
a multi-part upload.
I will talk about that later, if
you have a very large file.
So resumable upload, so here you
can see code snippets as
well showing how you do that.
You know, you will set which
range you want to upload or
download directly,
within a file.
Because we talk about large
files, so of course you don't
want to re-download or re-upload
a full file.
You can download just a specific
part of the file.
The gateway is here as well.
About security, how
does it work?
So there is a default ACL,
so Access Control List.
And then you can specify
ACLs per object.
So you can imagine specifying
permission to a technical
account, so a various set of
permissions, and then you can
map these permissions to
the relevant object.
And for browser access, we
use OAuth 2, as always.
So the gsutil, so that's
a preview.
But I'll open my terminal
from the Mac, to
show you how it works.
An example from Python,
so three lines.
You just type the library, and
the you pass the command.
And the URI is gs--
Google Storage--
semicolon slash slash.
And the REST way, we already
had an example before.
So the ecosystem--
these are the first ones, but
there are new ones since then
who are building solutions.
So I know that Panzura and
TwinStrata, for example, what
they do is that they sell
appliances to large companies.
And these appliances, the
companies put them in their
data center.
And they can then do like a
network share directly.
So from your Windows
environment, you can connect
to a network drive, and you
don't even know it's cloud
storage behind the scene.
So they export a type of
protocol, and they do caching,
so you have fast performance.
So some use cases--
and that's very useful
to augment.
You can say I have a limited
space, and I want to be able
to have more space, but I don't
know how much I need
cloud storage, because it's
pay per use, as always.
It's very nice to
have a burstable
zone, so you can extend.
That's the enterprise
use case.
So that's not a pretty slide,
but these are the main
features we see.
So bucket model--
we insist on the reliability.
So read after write, what we
really mean is that you can
really think of, I don't know,
uploading a one-terabyte file
from New York, and download
it three seconds
after from here, Roma.
And that will be
the same file.
You don't have to wait for
replication overnight.
This is really global,
live, realtime.
That's really the idea.
The API, we are interoperable
with Amazon S3.
I guess we imagine this is our
main competitor today.
I talked about the
access control.
And some new features about
notification, versioning, JSON
API, et cetera, et cetera.
Composite object as well--
composite object is nice,
because you imagine you have a
very large file.
We can split it in small files
and upload all of them in
parallel, so you can optimize
your bandwidth.
These are some examples of
the gcutil command line.
So this is pretty simple.
It is gcutil cp.
Gcutil is a simple binary you
can download in a zip or tar
format and run it from
any kind of terminal.
So this is using shell.
And it has basic functions,
but it has also
more advanced functions.
So here's a way you can get
gcutil-- gsutil, sorry.
There is some links to the
documentation, to the SDK.
And the Python package is
also available online.
Here are the main functions.
We won't go one by one, but just
to give you an idea of
what kinds of functions you
can do from gsutil.
Like the perfdiag, nice also
when you want to see if the
performance is good between
you and your
network in Cloud Storage.
The object composition that I've
been mentioning earlier--
so as you can see, first you
split your big file.
So that's really convenient
when you want to upload
hundreds of megabytes or
terabytes or more.
You can split your file.
You can do a multi-part
upload, so
it will run in parallel.
So you can define a number
of threads you
want to run in parallel.
And then it will compose.
And then, at the end,
you delete--
the composer will regroup into
a big file, your parts files,
and at the end, you delete
your parts files.
So that's one way to
upload a very, very
large amount of data.
One example--
five petabytes in five weeks,
so that's where we use case
from the UK.
We can't disclose the name of
the customer, but it has
millions of users.
It's doing backups
for end users.
And they had to migrate
from Amazon S3 into
Google Cloud Storage.
And what we explain here is that
they started earlier this
year, like in January,
February.
And that is the type of
performance we get.
Because we have, as we said,
a strong network.
So we have pretty good
connections with other big
cloud players.
So 10 gigabytes per second,
even more when
we reach the peaks.
And how does it work?
How do we implement such
a large upload?
So that's how it works.
So again, when I said earlier in
my presentation, we see App
Engine as an orchestrator, so
App Engine is very convenient
for that kind of usage.
So it will directly start to
create the test use that will
download from Amazon
S3 and then
upload from Cloud Storage.
Compute Engine here is the right
product to implement the
migration workers data.
And then you can imagine, you
can spin 1 to 10 to 100
machines, as much as you want.
You would be limited, of course,
by the network, not by
the number of machines.
And then it will upload
directly into
the migration bucket.
And the idea is that you
need to check for
that type of big upload.
You need to check the
consistency of the files.
So you can do directly that with
CRC, from another worker.
That's the type of architecture
to upload a very
large amount of files.
So as I said, we are using
it internally, always.
All Google projects are always
projects we choose to build
because we couldn't
find the right
technology on the market.
It's true for Gmail.
It's true for all
Google projects.
So all these Google projects are
using Google Cloud Storage
today, maybe even more, because
this slide is not
really recent.
And of course, Big Query and
Prediction, which are two
other Cloud Platform projects.
What you do is you always
upload on Cloud Storage.
And from Big Query, you
have one command.
So you can load into Big
Query before you
run your SQL requests.
Prediction is using the Cloud
Storage the same way.
OK, so let me show you
the gsutil stuff--
so I need to sit down, sorry--
and the UI.
And so first with the
UI, so that's it.
So here I am on the
cloud.google.com/console.
This is really where you have
access to all your services.
I am on the Cloud Service
project for this--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BASTIEN LEGRAS: Sorry?
Oh, you don't see the
URL, exactly.
Yeah, I don't know why,
because the projector
is going too high.
OK, it's not really important.
The idea--
I can show it, so
cloud.google.com/console.
This is where you see
your console.
From where do you see it?
From there.
So it's OK.
So in Cloud Storage--
so this is the web
UI for Cloud Storage.
You see all the buckets
on the left.
So here, we are on the
internal Google
demo platform project.
So it's not only me.
I have my bucket right there,
bastien-test, where I have
some files.
And the idea is you can drag and
drop directly a file from
your explorer--
sorry, it's not a good
idea, because Chrome
is overriding that.
Let's go with this
type of file.
OK, let's do that that way.
Normally, I have
drag and drop.
But basically--
let that go away.
So it will upload the
file directly, and
you will see it here.
And you can do exactly
the same type of
operation from gsutil.
I don't know if the resolution
is good enough for you.
Can you see?
So that's the list of commands
we have on gsutil.
And basically, you
just do a cp.
So I'm going to first delete
this file so you can see it if
I come back.
So you can delete the object
directly from here.
I'm doing it here with a small
object, but I've been
uploading, as you can see.
Sorry.
It's coming back.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BASTIEN LEGRAS: Yeah.
I've been told that you
don't see very well.
So that's the list of the
buckets on the left.
So you will see them
as root folders.
And I am currently showing
one bucket which is mine,
bastien-test, where I have some
files that I have uploaded.
And I wanted to highlight
that--
that's not even a
very large file.
As I said, we can go up
to five terabytes.
So you can drag and drop
normally from the browser.
And you can also upload--
so that's what I wanted
to show--
from gsutil directly.
This is how you're going
to use it afterwards.
So I am right now in
my local folder.
And I'll just do a cp test with
the PDF I was uploading
directly to the bucket.
You don't see it?
Right there.
Thanks to the Apple OS.
So it's uploading the PDF.
And now I would force
a refresh.
And you see my PDF is back
there, uploading right now.
It's in local time.
OK, so very easy.
So of course, there are many,
many other commands.
You can use the multi-thread
version, et cetera.
Let's try the perf stuff.
No, not the right one.
How is it?
Gsutil--
oh, there is a [INAUDIBLE]
command line for that.
So I won't go into all the
commands, but the idea is that
it's really simple.
You have your commands
right there.
You can upload your files,
download your files, and do
multi-part uploads as well.
And this is the UI, so you can
do basic operations, like
working on the object
permissions, which group has
access to what.
And that's, of course, live.
That's, of course--
this is updated live on the
[INAUDIBLE] of the object.
OK, I've been quite fast
on Cloud Storage.
So now what we're going to do is
go with the infrastructure
in general in Compute Engine.
But what I would like, so unless
someone tells me you
have already seen the video,
but it's five minutes long.
It's Urs Holzle, our director.
Has anyone already seen
that video, Cloud
Platform Track Kickoff?
It's really, really key.
But because this guy is the
first engineer at Google.
He's now head of the world
infrastructure, so within
which we have Cloud Platform.
He's really inspiring.
So I prefer to let
him talk for five
minutes, rather than me.
So it will explain to you what
we have been doing for 14
years with our data centers,
our network.
I think it's really important
for you to understand that
before I go on Compute Engine,
which is the virtualization
machine technology.
I will do some demo as well.
So I hope the network
is with us.
And I would like to have to
have a mic, the red one.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
BASTIEN LEGRAS: Let's
stop there.
If you want to see the whole
video, you just search--
I will show you after, because
I want to work on
this slide as well.
So it's really interesting to
see all these projects.
Maybe you haven't heard about
[INAUDIBLE] from Java, because
these are usually our internal
code names for projects.
What you need to understand is
that we built App Engine
Datastore, it was Big
Table right away.
So the initial Datastore of App
Engine when App Engine was
released in 2008, it's
Cloud Data Storage.
The Cloud Data Storage
of today originated
from here, Big Table.
What you see here, Colossus,
from last year, it's Google
Cloud Storage.
So it was a great introduction
to Google Cloud Storage.
I should have put it before my
Cloud Storage presentation.
So this is the internal name
of Google Cloud Storage.
And Dremel is the internal
name of Google Big Query.
So we have all these internal
technologies we had to build
because we couldn't find any
technology in the market to
serve our needs.
And when we see that other
people are interested by this
kind of technology, we just
choose a name, an external
name for it, and pricing, and we
build a website, and we put
the product online.
That's really the idea of what
we're doing on Cloud Platform,
is giving you the consequence of
our research, of a product
that we use every day, so you
can use it for your own needs.
So having your application
powered by our cloud, that's
really the general idea.
And if you search for these kind
of videos, just to show
you where you can find it, so
this is on-- you search for
Google I/O sessions.
And you will go there.
And on Google Cloud Platform,
you will see all the sessions.
And you have very interesting
things.
For Cloud Storage, you have a
13-minute video, usually,
importing a large data set.
My presentation was inspired
from that, of course.
And then the backend we
discussed this morning.
From Nothing to Nirvana in
Minutes, Cloud Backend for
your Android App
was also there.
So I really encourage you to
have a look, because these are
our project manager architects
who are explaining how we
think you could use
our technology.
So now let's switch
to Compute Engine.
Now you had a great introduction
from Urs, and you
better understand what kind
of work we've been doing.
So we'll start with a few
slides, and then with a demo.
And then we'll go for
the coffee break.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BASTIEN LEGRAS: Sure, sorry.
And by the way, if you have
questions on Cloud Storage
before I jump on
Compute Engine.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I have just a
couple of questions.
The first one is, is your
strong read after write
consistency model covered
by your SLA?
BASTIEN LEGRAS: Yeah.
It's part of the SLA.
AUDIENCE: OK.
The second one will
be, does it still
cover the listing feature?
BASTIEN LEGRAS: The listing
on Compute Engine?
AUDIENCE: I mean the consistency
model, does it
cover the listing of the objects
that are stored in the
Cloud Storage?
BASTIEN LEGRAS: Yeah, because
it's metadata.
So the idea is that a bucket
is an object with children,
because this is a tree model.
AUDIENCE: So every time I
require a list of the objects
that I stored, I get a full read
after write consistent
list of the objects?
BASTIEN LEGRAS: Yeah, exactly.
That's one of the features.
If you have other questions--
yeah, one over there.
AUDIENCE: I would like to know
which are the differences
between the Google Drive APIs
and the Google Cloud Storage?
And when do you recommend
to use one with
respect to the other?
BASTIEN LEGRAS: That's
a good question I
have from many customers.
So it's like the Chrome
versus Android battle.
No, frankly, Drive
is user storage.
So you have your little client
you can use to synchronize
your folder on your Mac or PC.
You have viewers, you
have 25 viewers.
You can view PDFs, AutoCAD
files, any
Office files, et cetera.
And on Drive, we put now the
focus on fidelity with
Microsoft Office.
That's our focus.
So it's really user storage.
Whereas here, Cloud Storage,
even if you see the UI where
you can list, et cetera, this
UI will be only for
administrators.
You won't to give that to users,
because this is really
optimized for heavy usage,
very, very large files.
So of course you could
upload three doc
flies in cloud storage.
When you click, it will
re-download the files.
So use Drive instead.
Then it's a matter of load--
not load, but oversize.
So Cloud Storage--
Drive is up to 30
gigabytes now.
We have a common--
and there was an announcement
with Gmail.
We now put the storage.
And here, with Cloud Storage,
you can go to petabytes,
virtually no limits.
AUDIENCE: Are there any
differences with respect to
permissions we can assign to
files in Google Drive and in
Cloud Platform Storage?
BASTIEN LEGRAS: So in Drive,
you set the permissions in
owner, viewer, editor, to other
users in your domain or
any Google account.
Or you get even put it fully
visible on the web, or anyone
with the link.
There are various models.
And again, Cloud Storage
and Drive are
totally different products.
This is not the same thing.
Cloud Storage is really for
application storage.
So you can define [INAUDIBLE]
and permissions to a Google
account, but it will be always
a technical account.
It wouldn't be a user account
for an end user, usually.
It can be a group, a technical
group, et cetera.
Because in Cloud Storage,
you will never
expose it to the user.
You will always use it as a
backend of your application,
and your application will talk
to Cloud Storage and talk to
the user, but not the user
to Cloud Storage.
That's not a real use
case that we see.
The closest the user can be to
Cloud Storage is when you have
the Panzura stuff with an
appliance, where it's browsing
Cloud Storage, but
is connecting to
the appliance, actually.
And just before, on Drive,
I said 30 gigabytes.
You can buy more storage.
It's not limited.
It's what you have by default.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BASTIEN LEGRAS: You're
welcome.
OK.
I want to move on to
Compute Engine.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
Just a small addition.
I think that you can use Drive
also when you have to manage
some personal kind of storage.
So for example, an Android is
very good to use Drive to
store the preferences
of your applications
or stuff like that.
Instead, I think that Cloud
Storage is better when you
have to store something that is
globally available, or not
to related to just one
user, more or less.